saviez-vous que dans la haute valet de
Chevreuse un magicien des saveurs opère
il s'appelle marchenenus c'est un maître
artisan siropi qui transforme les
saveurs en hectare inspiré des
traditions médiévales il renoue avec cet
art ancestral de la siroprie où le sirop
n'était pas qu'une boisson mais aussi un
ingrédient culinaire
[Musique]
raffine c'est donc au cœur de la cité
médiévale de Chevreuse près du château
de la Madeline que se trouve son bar à
Siro c'est un lieu coszy où l'alchimiste
et ses elfes vous emmènent pour un
voyage CHANS rel uni imaginez-vous
entrer dans cette boutique au son d'un
carillon et découvrir ces effluves aussi
envoûtantes que mystérieux des
aromatiques au fruité en passant par les
florales les épicés et les toréfi chaque
sirop est une œuvre d'art basilque
citron Bella fig Vervain gingembre tous
sont créés sans aucun arôme artificiel
ni colorant ni conservateur c'est un
cadeau qui raviera les palais les plus
exigeants et qui apportera une touche
d'originalité à vos
fête